[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
and welcome to part three
of this series on using Google
Colab to code, train, and test
neural networks in the browser
without needing to install
any kind of a runtime.
In the previous
video, I showed you
how you can install
TensorFlow with Colab.
In this video,
I'll show you then
how you can use
TensorFlow to build
a neural network for breast
cancer classification.
It runs completely in
the browser using Colab,
and it's really quick
to train and test.
The data for training
this neural network
comes from the Diagnostic
Wisconsin Breast Cancer
Database.
You can find it at the
URL in the description.
It has close to 600
samples of data,
each from a cell biopsy,
where 30 features have
been extracted per cell.
I've pre-processed the
data into several CSV files
so we can just focus on
the neural network itself.
Let's now take a
look at the code
for training this neural
network using this data so you
can use that network to
then perform breast cancer
classification yourself.
Let's start with
uploading the CSV files.
Now, that's a really
neat thing in Colab,
that you can load
external data into it.
I'm going to load
my CSVs into panda
dataframes with this code.
Next, using Keros in
the sequential API,
I'm going to create
a neural network
with an input dimension of 30.
And that's because each of
these cells has 30 features.
And we'll then have a layer
of 16, then 8, then 6,
and then, finally, 1.
The final layer
will be activated
by a Sigmoid function,
which will push it
towards a 1 or a 0.
Now we're classifying two
features, so that's perfect.
The network itself will
need to have a loss function
and an optimizer defined on it.
On each iteration, it measures
how well it did in training
using the loss function.
It then tries to improve on
that using the optimizer.
And as you'll see in a
moment, the training process
has 100 steps, with this
loop happening once per step.
The training itself takes
place in the Fit function.
Here, I pass in the
training x's and y's, and I
specify how many
times it will loop,
where a loop is it making
a guess at the relationship
between the x and the y.
It measures how well or how
badly it does using the loss
function, and then it
improves on its guess
using the optimizer.
It's coded to do that
100 times, but you
can amend that easily
and explore the results
for yourself.
As you'll see, once
it finishes training,
the loss is 0.0595, showing
that it's about 94% accurate.
We can now test that
network with data
that the neural network
hasn't yet seen.
This is the x-test data.
So we'll get a set of y
predictions for this data.
Now, these predictions are
going to be a probability.
They're not a 0 or
a 1, but values that
are close to 0 or close to 1.
So we'll write this code that
takes all of the values that
are less than 0.5 and
consider that to be 0
and everything else to be a 1.
And now, here's some
simple code that
will compare the
predicted values
for the test set
against the actual known
values for the same set.
Now, there were 114
values in this test set,
and you'll see it
gets it 100% correct.
Now, remember earlier we said
it was about 94% accurate.
So why do you think it
gets it 100% correct?
Well, that's a little
homework for you to do.
Post your answers in
the comments below
and let's see who
can get it right.
And that's it for this episode.
And in the next
video in this series,
my colleague,
Paige, will show you
about how to use different
runtimes and processors
and how to use your code to
take advantage of GPUs and TPUs
right in your browser.
So whatever you do, don't forget
to hit that subscribe button,
and you'll be able
to catch up with it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]